94% des français s'estiment heureux de
vivre dans leur pays selon un sondage de
mars 2018
mais alors pourquoi six mois après
280000 gilet jaune défaire de thil dans
toute la france et des semaines durant
crie-t-il leur dénuement et leurs
souffrances
[Musique]
les opinions des français au sujet de
leur pays et d'un grand nombre de
phénomènes de l'économie notamment sont
très négatives alors que les paramètres
socio économique de notre pays sont
plutôt assez bon
[Musique]
j'ai comparé le pays aux 27 autres pays
d'europe grâce à des enquêtes par
sondage dit eurobaromètre qui sont
passés dans les 28 pays européens
et puis grâce aussi aux données sur par
exemple le niveau de prestations
sociales ou bien le taux de pauvreté va
des données objectives sur l'état du
pays et la france est de loin le pays
d'europe où l'écart est le plus grand
entre le ressenti et les faits les
demandes des gilet jaune me paraissait
peu en conformité avec ce que j'avais
dans mes chiffres et dans mes cartes
notamment les gilet jaune par exemple se
plaignait que les retraités les
personnes âgées étaient très pauvres
or la france est au contraire le pays
d'europe où les retraités et les
personnes âgées sont le moins pauvres
[Musique]
j'ai repensé et bien sûr aux deux grands
ouvrages de tocqueville l'ancien régime
et la révolution et de la démocratie en
amérique
j'ai pensé aussi aux travaux d'un
historien et sociologue américain albert
hirschman qui lui s'intéresse au divorce
qui existe entre plusieurs composantes
des classes moyennes
[Musique]
mon espoir est que les français soient
un peu plus attentif au fait qu'ils ne
se laissent pas simplement bercé par des
émotions qui les amène à avoir du
ressenti
[Musique]